I just noticed nice hey guys we're
walking around the BuzzFeed offices
today asking for people's thoughts on
music festivals the only thing they
don't know is I have a little surprise
for them I like to think of my
co-workers as my friends I like to think
they're gonna stop me from looking like
an idiot but I could be wrong let's go
around and ask and see if anyone's gonna
interrupt me though just be ready for
that yes you are a good person
do you have any experience with music
festivals I've never been to a music
festival yeah yeah which ones uh I went
to made-in-america gonig of all what's
the drawback for you seems exhausting
seems really dirty and loud and like
there's nowhere to pee if you were with
friends would you stop your friend from
doing something stupid or looking stupid
I would absolutely not stop any friends
from doing something dumb I'm a good
friend in that way totally stop it stop
a bad wardrobe situation what if what if
someone you were talking to had
something in their teeth would you would
you say anything to them then so this
videos about it it might be oh you have
something to do okay would you say
anything to them absolutely not
absolutely when did you first notice
within the first question we got it
that's what we're doing here today no
that's good what if someone had
something in their teeth would you say
anything to them then see
[Music]
okay after oh my gosh was that really in
that's it we want to see if anyone's
gonna interrupt me oh I wasn't even
gonna let you start come on now well if
you see that do you do you intervene I
feel like I haven't picked a side on
this hmm
I just like to see people embarrassed
for the most part I don't know it's so
awkward it is awkward cuz you don't want
to make someone feel worse but I also
would never let you leave yeah I think
I'm definitely that that person that
tells you right away cuz it almost
embarrasses me to look at your mouth you
have to tell people that is just like
basic pleasantries of socialization yeah
of course it's embarrassing like whether
I see like a booger or something in
their teeth or whatever you know I just
have to let them know I really don't
know what is right we're exploring that
here today I like that sounds like the
moral the story everywhere here is we
just need to be need to look out for
each other and it's okay for that little
thing of awkward we can suffer through
it and then I was like man you totally
that like that deep in there so it's
deep it's real deep
it looks like you had a really great
lunch I'm still enjoying it apparently